I want to talk about what I am now
calling news brain space because we talk
a lot about the 24 hour news cycle and
how everyone wants to get every opinion
out immediately and attack it and you
know go through the motions with it and
all that but one thing I find really
really interesting is how all of us our
whole news system our whole media system
everything we can sort of only tackle
one thing at a time right so for almost
all of the summer we were dealing with
Isis Isis Isis then towards the tail end
of the summer into the fall then it was
Ebola Ebola Ebola then we moved on we
had like two weeks of immigration
immigration immigration now we've moved
on and we're in Ferguson Ferguson
Ferguson mode and it's like all these
things are always happening all at the
same time and yet if you watch the media
something will be incredibly important
on Monday something else happens on
Tuesday important thing for Monday
completely gone now we're focused on
Tuesday but guess what Tuesday is about
to disappear because you don't know
what's going to happen on Wednesday and
I think this is really really bad what I
really think that most of us can carry a
couple different things in our brains
even if you're really busy at work
really busy at home life but you have a
little space even for me who's in this
the media world or the news world or
whatever this online thing is I got a
life too but I am able to carve out a
little bit of space to put all this
stuff in and I think it's important that
when something happens something big
something huge and culturally important
like what's going on in Ferguson right
now that the media doesn't need to
necessarily focus on that 24 hours
relentlessly yes you can put a lot of
coverage in that but suddenly what was
incredibly important yesterday
immigration the debate about what's
going on there and and you know what
Republicans would say it is an abuse of
power what Democrats would say is a
necessary action because of a stalled
government or Ebola what happened it
doesn't seem to be in America anymore
right but yeah there's still a lot of
people dying in West Africa we cared a
lot about it two weeks ago and I
guarantee you right now if you went on
wherever yahoo or CNN or Drudge or
whatever there probably isn't one
article on the front page about it it's
still happening so I think there's a
real danger in that would you be able to
put a whole bunch of things in at once
and talk about anything because they're
also sort of related how weary
act to Ebola is related to immigration
and our borders and things of that
nature and then thats related to
Ferguson and economic inequality and all
that so put a lot of things in your
brain I think you can handle it I'm
gonna do this I can